[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission ça tout le débat harcelées et
violées ou réifier des femmes célèbres
ou de simples anonymes ont pris la
parole depuis octobre dernier pour
dénoncer cette violence souterraine
souvent vieux minoré que l'on dit
invisible
le producteur américain harvey weinstein
soupçonné d'avoir agressé près d'une
centaine de femmes ainsi déclenché des
vagues d'indignation de dénonciation
plus de solidarité
mettant en lumière une banale violences
après les mois où sont les actes y at il
une véritable prise de conscience de
cette violence en france le projet de
loi présenté hier est il à la hauteur de
ce problème de société pour en parler
jacques alioto de moi marielle savina
déléguée aux droits des femmes dans le
département des yvelines
marie-laure houdaille avocat en droit de
victimes au barreau de versailles est
également olivia de boer grain cadre
socio éducative au chrs d'équinoxe un
centre d'hébergement de réinsertion
sociale à montigny le bretonneux qui
accueille également des femmes victimes
de violences bonsoir à vous tout ce
qu'on aime aussi d'avoir accepté cette
invitation
on va tout de suite entré dans le vif du
sujet ce que vous dans vos milieux
respectifs vous avez vu justement une
libération de la parole de femmes et un
changement après justement cette affaire
weinstein qui veut commencer ce que vous
avez vu non dans notre dans mon domaine
en tout cas
on n'a pas encore de changement et
enfants je continue à voir la difficulté
des victimes dans le le parcours
judiciaire ça vous n'avez pas lu plus de
plaintes plusieurs personnes qui ont osé
pour vous pousser votre porte ou quoi
que ce soit rien du tout non d'accord et
vous notamment dans votre centre
d'accueil
est-ce que vous avez vu davantage de
femmes légères les lieux au bout libère
si vous voulez ça se faisait déjà dire
qu'il ya un effet van staeyen pas plus
que ça je rejoindrai l'un des montagnes
mettre au dail sur la difficulté voire
des victimes est effectivement un
pouvoir apporter des preuves
c'est ça la difficulté aujourd'hui hein
c'est pas tant la willaya la
libéralisation de la parole
effectivement mais il ya aussi comment
haut démontre son statut et ça c'est un
parcours long et douloureux d'accord
pour que ce à dire que vous on va dire
sur le terrain ce que je veux dire ça
comme ça pour l'instant vous voyez pas
vraiment quelque chose en tout cas au
niveau du gouvernement ça vraiment être
une question qui a été présent oui tout
à fait alors après bien évidemment il
n'a pas arrêté
c'est pas la fermer riquet nous tous les
acheteurs qui ont fait que la question
des violences faites aux femmes
s'assoient violences sexuelles sexistes
ou sur l'espace public soit pris en
charge par le gouvernement
il ya différents plan interministériel
mis en place et en effet par contre on a
un effet médiatique incontournable avec
une nouvelle ère je dirais de la parole
des femmes donc peut-être nous vend
comment féministes qui arrive après les
droits sociaux et économiques des années
80 donc je pense qu'il ya une vraie
prise de parole que ça soit
gouvernementale associative pour
quelques augmentations de plaintes sur
le département des yvelines
vous savez de combien dans la vienne
après 16 en augmentation non parce que
ce sont des chiffres 2010 est et ils
soient tiendrons au courant 2018 donc
pour l'instant quelques commissariats
mon nom fait part par contre plutôt sur
les violences sexuelles
d'accord là mais plutôt des affaires
plus anciennes notamment gouvernement ou
emmanuel macron plus tout à fait une
déclaration aussi anglaise a fait
notamment que l'égalité homme femme
serait une cause nationale
l'incident en augmentant notamment les
budgets des trois livres aux femmes et
surtout en ce sens tu as he is an
jusqu'à la fin de ces cinq prochaines
années est-ce que vous en tant que
délégué sur ces questions là ce que vous
avez vu un changement ce que vous
appelez une ponctuation programmation
budgétaire donc j'en saurai un peu plus
au mois d'avril mai sur sur nos budgets
en effet il ya déjà la sanctuarisation
de certains de certains dispositifs
notamment des dispositifs porté
également par equinox qui est laquelle
deux jours donc qui sont des dispositifs
fléché or par le droit des femmes au
niveau régional des dispositifs
également comme moman safe à saint
germain en laye qui est un lieu
d'accueil et des augmentations donc en
tout cas les grands réseaux on va dire
que ça soit institutionnels ou
associatifs vont en tout cas être
maintenue
d'accord c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
est plutôt dans le maintien de ce qui
existe déjà ce que vous avez partant des
besoins spécifiques justement pour
beaucoup de besoins exhaustive d'accord
effectivement et ça s'est retenu et
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle sur le
cinquième plan c'est la cause des
enfants
ce qu'on oublie aussi des enfants
souvent qu'ils sont victimes et avec des
conséquences graves et une prise en
charge qui aujourd'hui n'est pas assez
développé voilà on a pas mal de
dispositifs existants sur le 78 et on
peut s'en féliciter quand même avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs et de
partenaires au niveau de la prise en
charge présent et qui maillent
l'ensemble du département donc ça c'est
plutôt la bonne nouvelle des difficultés
je disais effectivement avec métro die à
faire reconnaître donc dans un parcours
d'insertion
sur un centre d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale la femme n'arrive
pas toujours avec son statut de victime
vacances à câliner orale même anne
harris pas identifié à mettre dans ses
rangs elle a été victime ça lui a fait
quitter le domicile conjugal dans un
contexte où dans un autre et elle se
retrouve sans logement sans possibilité
en tout cas a effectivement de se mettre
à l'abri donc elle va arriver sur des
structures qui sont pas forcément toutes
spécialisées spécifiques
c'est un accompagnement spécifique donc
la liste exhaustive
elle serait en donnant encore plus de
moyens mais déjà le maintien des moyens
c'est déjà quelque chose de fort faut
quand même se satisfaire demande est
toujours plus oui mieux coordonné c'est
plutôt ça la vraie question c'est mieux
coordonner les liaisons entre la justice
entre les possibilités d'hébergement les
prises en charge aussi au niveau des
séquelles un des violences que les
violences vont avoir sur lesquels chacun
parle des femmes et séquelles
psychologiques énormes
des questions tentative de suicide voilà
le schéma est très très très très large
par contre moi ce que je peux vous dire
sur un parcours de réinsertion c'est
effectivement accompagné une femme
victime de violence c'est pas comme
accompagner une autre femme
pourquoi parce que il ya les
tergiversations aussi et tout ce que les
violences ont pu causer et qui va mettre
cette femme dans une situation où elle
va pas savoir va pas savoir vraiment ce
qu'elle veut elle va pas voir vraiment
savoir où elle va et est du coup pour
construire un projet d'accompagnement
avec la personne ça rend les choses
difficiles
donc c'est encore plus de coordination
mais ça c'est madame savina qui sans
qu'ils s'en chargent là quand même
depuis un certain nombre d'années et ça
commence à porter ses fruits puisque les
acteurs se connaissent mieux ce qui est
déjà ce qui est déjà pas mal
alors qu'avant il y avait beaucoup de
dispositifs existant déjà
mais avait pas forcément de liaison
entre eux ce qui est intéressant
notamment quand on doit géographiquement
faire déménager la femme et la mettre en
sécurité ou à l'abri ça c'est important
d'accord est ce que par exemple vous
dans votre cabinet vous avez des femmes
qui n'arrivent pas à mettre des mots et
qui ont déjà décidé de porter plainte ou
elle hésite encore quelques ajustements
le cheminement
alors il ya à peu près autant de cas
autant de situations que de femmes qui
viennent nous voir il y en a qui
viennent pour en effet une séparation
qui nous parle de divorce par
consentement mutuel qui veulent que tout
se passe bien etc
dans mon cabinet on utilise de plus en
plus on élabore des questionnaires dont
on aborde nous professionnels la
question de la violence aussi à travers
ce questionnaire c'est à dire est ce que
vous avez la jouissance de comptes
bancaires est ce que vous avez
l'utilisation de la voiture est ce que
vous avez les clés de la maison
voilà parce que les violences physiques
ça les femmes savent nous dire je suis
victime de violences parce qu'il m'a
cassé un bras mais
je n'ai pas accès aux comptes je ne peux
pas aller faire des courses tout seul ce
n'est pas l'usagé la voiture je n'ai pas
le droit de sortir sans être accompagnée
quand on leur dit que ça même sur les
sites gouvernementaux moi je les renvoie
beaucoup sur les sites pour leur dire
voilà c'est pas moi qui le dit et bien à
ce moment là beaucoup en effet tombe des
nues en disant ah bah non ça en effet je
n'ai pas à banon ça évidemment que j'ai
pas le droit
voilà mais après voilà sur des toutes
petites statistiques on leur dit parce
que je crois qu'elles ont aussi besoin
pour être rassurés je le disais c'est
vraiment un parcours extrêmement
difficile notamment une victime de
violences conjugales ont dit que c'est
cet aller retour avant de prendre la
vous ferez décision de départ d'accord
c'était oui je portais plainte non je
veux pas oui je vais quitter et non je
vais pas quitter il ya quand même les
enfants il ya quand même ils ont leur
école ils sont attachés à leurs amis
donc je pense aux enfants moi ce que je
vis c'est pas si grave que ça etc
voilà donc la moyenne c'est cet aller
retour donc il faut aussi nous en tant
que professionnel qu'on respecte ce
rythme là puisque le principe des
victimes par les auteurs c'est que l on
était considérés comme des objets si
nous professionnels en leur renvoie
cette image là et moi j'ai fait la
bourde pendant des années parce que je
n'étais pas formés ou pas suffisamment
formés on leur envoie des phrases
assassines dont madame faudrait quand
même vous décidez vous comprenez moi ça
fait deux fois que je présume que je
prépare une requête deux fois que vous
voulez pas que je la dépose
trois rendez vous comprenez finalement
vous réfléchissez finalement pas voilà
et nous on a notre temps de
professionnels donc avec un agenda
un peu chargé et puis leur temps à elle
qui n'est pas le même
donc ça nous il faut à travers les
formations ça moche voilà je veux srin
vraiment à travers l'information à
travers on le disait le travail en
réseau avec pareil mon cabinet mais je
pense de plus en plus d'avocats sont
conscients que nous ne pouvons pas notre
métier ne peut pas apporter toutes les
réponses à ces femmes là ces victimes là
moi je suis également avocat d'enfants
donc je travaille beaucoup auprès
d'enfants
on ne peut pas seul apporter toutes les
réponses
donc seul un travaux un travail pardon
en réseau avec un maillage où on peut
renvoyer vers des associations d'aidé
aux victimes on peut renvoyer vers voilà
des prix des professionnels psychologues
etc des structures hospitalières qui
peuvent ils à la question du logement
fin mais comment expliquer notamment ce
déni ou pas parce qu'après tout ça
rejoint pas dans votre exemple ça
rejoint notamment la forme d'emprise
mais il ya aussi quelque chose d'assez
tabou puisque si j'en crois les chiffres
notamment la plupart des personnes qui
ont été violées ont été violées par des
membres de leur famille pour un cercle
très proches à qui rend la chose encore
plus tabou c'est à dire que vous
aujourd'hui il ya toujours ce côté tabou
qui est très difficile à décortiquer à
cette sortir aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'il ya cette culpabilité et
à cette responsabilité
quand ça se passe justement en milieu
intrafamiliales l'enfant qui va dénoncer
les faits il sait très bien par exemple
que le père c'est le seul salaire de la
maison le team donc il fait tout
exploser s'il dénonce à il fait des
nombrils fait exploser peut-être le
couple de ses parents si ce n'est pas le
couple et qu'il y à une sorte de fusion
enfin où madame ne veut pas croire ne
peux pas croire parce que je pense que
quand on n'a jamais été confronté à ce
genre de nouvelles on peut pas savoir
comment on réagira si on croit le
conjoint si on croit l'enfant etc
et voilà
les enfants ont tout à fait conscience
quand même que ça va être un tsunami est
en toi s'il s'est compliqué il ya aussi
ensuite la parole notamment des preuves
notamment où c'est parole contre parole
à ce que l'ajustement il ya des
évolutions pour éviter notamment ça
c'est kalou effectivement ça devient
quelque chose d'assez stérile l'art
actuel sur le jeu vous va en outre il y
à des évolutions on a par exemple ça
vous été évoquée
on a la chance dans les yvelines d'avoir
maintenant un lieu en principe unique de
recueil de la parole de l'enfant victime
qui est l'unité d'accueil des mineurs
qui est au sein de l'ue m j l'unité
médico-judiciaire donc à versailles
versailles d'accord mais à versailles
pour tout le département
donc certes c'est une énorme
amélioration par rapport à ça fait 25
ans que j'exerce et une énorme
amélioration par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu
mais autant vous dire que voilà des
familles qui sont à mantes-la-jolie
qu'on a jamais quitté mentent quand on
leur dit allez prendre rendez vous enfin
vous avez rendez vous il faut aller à
versailles
maison d'espagne etc éventuellement on
les perd on les a à un moment donné on
les envoie à tel ou tel endroit
et là c'est fini ils n'ont pas d'accord
comment fait justement peut-être par
nouveau pouvoir permettre aux personnes
d'avoir pouvoir appliquer jouir de leurs
droits tout simplement je pense qu'avant
tout c'est il faut faire en sorte
qu'aucune violence en tout cas déclarés
dit un professionnel ne reste sans
réponse donc en effet je rejoins
marie-laure de dire en effet il faut
former les professionnels donc aussi
bien dans les auditions que ce soit les
policiers les gendarmes il ya un eu un
vrai effort en tout cas de formation
aussi bien national que départemental
dernièrement il ya également un texte de
loi sur les médecins donc c'est à dire
de nommer dans chaque urgence donc un
médecin coordinateur et référent
violences conjugales substitut du
procureur bien évidemment référence
violences conjugales donc on voit bien
évidemment qui aujourd'hui c'est une
politique interministérielle que c'est
pas que la question d'injustice état que
la question d'association en tout cas de
porteurs de deux projets sur les
territoires c'est pas que les militantes
féministes non plus c'est vraiment un
maillage et je dirais même que c'est un
maillage qui doit se faire avec la
société
c'est à dire que que ça soit quelqu'un
dans un cabinet de médical que ça soit
un médecin un coiffeur quand on entend
parler des violences on doit se dire la
parole doit être cueillie et à doite
orienter efficacement et orienter
efficacement je pense que c'est vraiment
se dire je dis pas je vous envoie là
parce que c'est eux qui sont les mieux
placés c'est je vous envoie vers m
houdaille où je vous envoie vers olivia
parce que je connais et je sais que le
travail sera efficace donc en effet la
formation allait primordial l'éducation
nationale également efforts mais il ya
je pense qu'on va monter en charge
progressivement bien évidemment je
parlais juste avant avec un cfa je pense
que même dans les cfa il ya bien
évidemment toute la question des
stéréotypes aussi travailler la stère et
les sérotypes un fils gars ont travaillé
sur les relations aussi fille garçon au
coeur de
de la société civile au plus près en
tout cas des habitants et habitantes
d'accord est-ce que c'est facile
commente expliquer à ces femmes victimes
de violences qu'elles ont des droits et
qu'elles doivent tout simplement les
faire valoir ce que c'est quelque chose
de facile à faire entendre c'est
également alors ça peut être long et
douloureux parfois parce que ça renvoie
des choses aussi de dire à une personne
vous êtes victime et que certaines
femmes sont tellement 1 il est
effectivement par l'expérience vécue je
prends l'exemple d'une femme que j'ai en
tête 25 ans de violences conjugales
alors droit à rien yves nice a l'air
alors qu'elle travaillait enfin ça
allait très très très loin
ça a duré un an et demi un an et demi
pour qu'elle prenne conscience
entre le moment où elle est arrivée à
l'accueil de jour avec son statut de
femme victime de violence et le moment
où elle a dit ça y est stop
j'arrête je vais faire une procédure de
divorce
je vais effectivement faire valoir mes
droits un an et demi on n'efface pas des
années et des années d'emprise qu'elle
soit psychologique parce que là c'est
comme disait m houdaille cesser les
séquelles elles sont même pas mesurable
dire qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
statistiques possible sur les
conséquences réelles des violences
psychiques cc c'est impressionnant comme
disait m houdaille d'aller voir la
police avec un bras cassé
c'est simple d'aller à la police en
disant voilà on m'empêche ça ne
m'empêche ça ne m'empêche pas c'est pas
aussi simple que ça le problème de la
preuve là intervient aussi à partir de
quel moment et c'est vrai la formation
des policiers des gendarmes elle est
absolument indispensable mais j'ai envie
de dire le réseau de santé alors c'est
bien aux urgences parce que là on y
arrive on est déjà abîmée mais le
médecin de ville comme médecin de ville
qu'ils rencontrent en vain pendant 25
ans cette femme ça pourrait être
intéressant qu'il soit associé à ça
futurs médecins le maillage
effectivement et la complémentarité des
interventions qu'elle soit du côté de la
justice qu'elle soit du côté de la santé
qu'elle soit du côté la prise en charge
de l'accompagnement au niveau logements
ou hébergements très très très c'est
très important c'est essentiel si on
travaille chacun de notre côté on n'y
arrive pas ces gens croit les chiffres
notamment une dernière étude de l'ifop
qui est sorti au mois de janvier
il explique notamment que près de 12%
des femmes ont vécu au moins une fois
dans sa vie un viol donc c'est à dire
que tout le monde ici autres tableaux
toaster vous certainement beaucoup plus
que les autres connaissent au moins une
personne a impliqué ce qu'il ya des
moyens devoir d'aider ou du conseil tout
simplement donné
pour savoir si quelqu'un justement soit
en prie je vous paraissent que
les personnes qui observaient ce genre
de violence avec mondiale aussi
harcèlement agression ce genre de choses
sont aujourd'hui contrainte par la loi
de giresse qu'il ya un glissement vers
ce terrain là aujourd'hui à son conseil
et obligations aujourd'hui oui non alors
site intégré dans la loi en effet c'est
une obligation c'est une obligation pour
tout citoyen c'est une obligation a crû
pour tout professionnel les moyens c'est
par exemple le train le 39 19
pour tout ce qui est violence faite aux
femmes alors voilà c'est le thème
et puis mais c'est encore pire pour les
hommes qui car il y en a et donc eux ils
ne se retrouve nulle part dans ce qu'ils
appellent ils ont refusé
mais il n'appelle pas non on n'appelle
pas 69 à 39,19 vous regardez tout le
site et vous êtes femme vous êtes
victimes etc
il ya une seule association en france
qui s'appelle sos hommes battus battu
donc tous ne se sentent pas battu
notamment quand ils subissent également
des violences psychologiques les femmes
n'étant pas exemptes
non plus ce genre de personnalité donc
voilà donc elles peuvent être auteur il
a encore plus difficile pour un homme
mais donc après sur voilà sur les moyens
les conseils qu'on peut leur donner je
vous dis là encore ce sont assez tous
maillage c'est le fait qu'il y ait
vraiment une prise en charge globale
il y à tous ces postes extrêmement
efficace d'intervenants sociaux en
commissariats et gendarmeries d'accord
pour c'est à dire qu'un citoyen lambda
ou quelqu'un qui voit ne veut rien faire
il faut tôt pris le donne et l'orienter
vers un professionnel voilà oui vacances
la finition la corde tout à fait une
année quel que soit le professionnel
ensuite s'agissant évidemment de
deux situations très intime pour les
gens très compliqué à raconter parce
qu'ils se sentent dévalorisés parce que
ils ont très peur de ne pas être crue ce
qui malheureusement il arrive encore
notamment dans les violences
psychologiques
on a véritablement des phrases encore
par des professionnels de vous n'allez
pas en faire tout un foin tout le monde
a vécu à peu près ça
ces terres à des commissariats qu'ils
disent malgré l'obligation on a un
article 1 les lois elles existent elles
sont assez protectrices on a un article
article 15-3 du code de procédure pénale
qui dit que toute plainte ya une
obligation des commissariats et des
gendarmeries les prendre eh bien on a
encore moi je suis amené très
régulièrement à prendre mon téléphone
pour dire j'ai une cliente qui ressort
de chez vous qui me dit qu'elle n'a pas
pu déposer plainte
d'accord ça ça sache toujours ça reste
courant avec alain leurs contraintes à
eux c'est à dire une charge de travail
un manque de moyens là aussi les lois
mois contre en tant qu'avocat évidemment
mais derrière quel moyen rajouter
on évoquait pour ce soir aussi le
harcèlement de rue ces nouveaux délits
c'est une chose alors d'abord mois sur
les définitions entre harcèlement et de
rue je pense qu'on va avoir quelques
soucis en revient pas on va tout de
suite abordé d'ailleurs le sujet puisque
son honneur en ses rangs des tout
doucement donc hier la secrétaire d'état
marlène schiappa recharge et de
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes a
présenté donkey hier son projet de loi
elle propose notamment la création de
une contravention pour délit d'outragé
qui s'élève à 90 euros mais également
d'étendre la notion de versements morale
sexuelle pour l'appliquer notamment aux
hawks ibères harcèlement groupe et sur
une personne
on va écouter un extrait ou a expliqué
présentant sa loi bien évidemment elle
ne se suffit pas à elle seule mais elle
est déjà très forte et très ambitieuse
nous pensons que cette loi elle était
applicable les lois de la république
affirme très clairement qui n'est plus
permis d'harceler d'intimider des femmes
des enfants des hommes également demande
qu'il ya aussi des hommes qui sont
victimes
que ce soit dans l'espace public dans
les transports ou sur l'espace numérique
est ce que justement ce genre de
de mesures notamment le délit d'outragé
aussi l'agrandissement d'élargissement
va dire d harcèlement moral et sexiste
ça va vraiment protéger davantage que
les lois qui existent déjà aujourd'hui
ce que ça va vraiment être applicable
est ce que savoir en effet concret ça
vient d'eux ça vient d'être présentée
donc jamais ce qu'il va falloir voir sur
la durée
je pense que la question de d'élargir
les notions de violences sexuelles ces
deux suisses existe au niveau du
harcèlement cyberharcèlement je pense
que c'est très important
on voit aujourd'hui que les réseaux
sociaux sont quand même un réservoir de
propos qu'ils soient homophobe sexiste
voire plus avec une démultiplication de
par le réseau social on est anonyme
derrière notre écran
je pense que ça c'est dans la bonne voie
pour l'autre h etc si je pense que c'est
une c'est un projet de loi qui est plus
symbolique de dire qu' il n'est il est
inadmissible sur l'espace public une
femme ou un homme qu'une jeune femme se
fasse harcelées verbalement pour un
numéro de téléphone pour un habillement
qui serait pas les voilà qui serait pas
dans les bons codes ses symboles y
ensuite qu'est ce qui est justement un
harcèlement
sexuelle est ce que c'est un regard est
ce que c'est vous êtes jolie
mademoiselle est ce que ça passe ou pas
justement où est la frontière ou les
lignes rouges la fonction c'est la
frontière que vont se poser les femmes
et les jeunes femmes c'est à dire que
c'est je pense que quelques déjà le
harcèlement on est sur un phénomène qui
est répétée si je me trompe pas donc il
faut que la le harceleur soit insistant
que les propos viennent bien évidemment
pas respecter la dignité humaine que ça
soit en sueur sur la façon de s'habiller
ou autre et puis après c'est la
frontière elle est différente rentrer
peut-être marie laure olivier en moi
peut-être que quelque chose moi je
mettrais un curseur de respect serait
irrespectueux pour quelqu'un d'autre
donc il va d'abord falloir voir comment
chacun et chacune dont se positionner en
tant que citoyens citoyennes pour est
important la contravention pour aller
nettement et uniquement à être appliquée
s'il ya là plus de sécurité du quotidien
à proximité donc ce que ce n'est pas si
sûr c'est sur un flagrant délit en effet
près dans les transports en commun on
voit tous ces phénomènes de frotteur
également notamment dans le métro
parisien il y a des brigades qui sont en
civil et qui peuvent aussi venir en aide
notamment à des des voyageuses qui sont
importunés et c'est déjà arrivé qu'il ya
eu des examens dans ce sens là encore
avant bien avant le texte on voit ça un
dernier petit tour de table avant la fin
de cette émission quelques propositions
notamment pour améliorer
et on pauvres afin d'endiguer ce
phénomène de violences sexuelles
qu'est ce que vous pourrez faire pour
éviter ça pour endiguer ce phénomène est
ce qu'il ya des propositions des
solutions qui n'ont pas encore été sauvé
jusqu'à présent je pensais plutôt une
sensibilisation en amener à l'éducation
à la sexualité faire en sorte que
l'éducation ou rapports de sexe ou bien
évidemment soit beaucoup plus développé
que ce soit au sein de l'éducation
nationale ou au sein d'une structure
jeunesse ou structures de jeunes je
pourrais en serrant éducation je vais
vite rejoindre sabina parce
qu'effectivement clairement c'est
l'éducation s'est laissé sociétale il ya
des choses aujourd'hui que même nous
alors qu'on travaille dans cette
problématique de façon intrinsèque
on transmet donc oui à l'éducation parce
qu'il faut commencer par une base
évidemment endiguer les comportements
déviants c'est une grande question vous
poser est est ce qu'on y arriverait un
jour je suis pas sûr par contre agir par
la masse un dernier mot pour conclure
cette émission comme en demi teinte où
un tout petit bémol
alors qui est peut-être plus personnel
qui qui est aussi d'être attentif aux
risques de diabolisation
moi je suis parent je n'ai pas envie non
plus que mes enfants vivent dans un
climat plus anxiogène qui ne peut l'être
à l'heure actuelle je n'ai pas envie
que tous les hommes tous les garçons
soient vus comme des pervers sexuels
palais trop dans l'ensemble toujours la
même chose c'est une question en effet
la vie libre de respect l'apprentissage
du respect de l'autre de l'intégrité
physique de l'autre
merci à vous tous d'avoir accepté de
participer à cette émission quant à vous
je vous invite à voir ou à revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet passent
une agréable soirée
il ya la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
tous